[Musique]
mon père était un vrai bâtard il avait l'habitude de
mettre des cigares sur mon bras sadique baise
n'importe quoi de
pervers comme toi je l'ai tué quand j'avais 9
ans qui es-tu tu as une
fille vraiment spéciale elle mérite d'être libre n'est-
ce pas  pense que tu peux venir ici et
prendre ce qui m'appartient ouais qu'en
penses-tu
[Musique]
méfie-toi des faux prophètes qui viennent à toi
en vêtements de brebis mais intérieurement ce
sont des loups ravisseurs
Jésus est le berger qui te protège toi
et ta famille de ceux  règles et je
suis son chien le chien de berger a
remis les terres sur les rails quand ils se sont écartés
du chemin et certains d'entre vous se sont égarés
n'est-ce pas
nous vous amènerons des gens que l'or est
bien disposé envers vous laissez-moi vous remettre sur le
droit chemin  ceux qui le méritent vont en enfer
je pourrais vous parler de l'enfer de ses
flammes de la douleur je suis sûr que
vous avez essayé d'imaginer ce que
c'est c'est pire
ma contribution il vient non rejoignons nous
en chantant restez avec moi d'accord
[Musique  ]
[Musique]
il n'est pas n  ne va jamais t'arrêter
toi
ou faux prophète viens à toi en vêtements de brebis
ou intérieurement ce sont des loups ravisseurs
Jésus en plus de prétendre que tu meurs
chien
tu t'es égaré et toi
je suis ici pour te punir et généralement les
présentations d'automne viennent en fait de moi  veux dire
ta mère
mon cousin data Locker je sais que tu es
là et je sais que tu peux m'entendre tu peux
avoir
le moment où tu utilises
[Music]
nous devons afficher avec le développeur
je dois attendre longtemps pour te trouver à qui
elle appartient  Hell River
je me souviens bien d'elle
[Musique
] c'était une guerrière
[Musique]